absolutely wonderful day yesterday
for watching conservatives destroy the
libs on television I thought that focus
group talking to that MSNBC reporter and
correcting her facts repeatedly it was
such a breath of fresh air it was so
delightful and then it was followed up
by my pal Senator Ted Cruz going on The
View and absolutely reading those poor
cackling hens the riot act try to say
the election was fair and square and
legitimate you know who y'all don't do
that to you don't do it to Hillary
Clinton who stood up and said Trump
stole the elections
who said that the election was stolen
they sat here and said it was
illegitimate and you guys were fine with
it okay so it's illegitimate the
Republicans
no you know here's the thing we may not
like when Republicans win but we don't
go and we don't storm we don't try to
change
[Applause]
did I miss an entire year of antifa
riots where cities across this country
your position is the left doesn't engage
in violence really no they wanted to
know I'm our friend Mike Pence
just accused us of doing something we
didn't do you said Hillary Clinton
didn't say whatever she didn't say I'm
saying to you listen
and she said we stand here and you were
fine with her saying it was illegitimate
she called Donald Trump the next morning
and she conceded the election Ted okay
[Applause]
Trump is an illegitimate president
Hillary Clinton says the election is
stolen from you Hillary Clinton in 2002
George W Bush was selected Not Elected
Joe Biden Al Gore was was elected
president so Joe Biden yeah
I love it at the end the only thing that
they've got the only thing that they can
possibly say is hey hey
keep your voice down
that's it Anna Navarro who's one of the
two fake Republicans on The View there's
the the three Libs and then the two fake
Republicans Anna Navarro and that chick
who worked in the Trump Administration
and but they're both effectively
Democrats and all they ever do is
support Democrats and so after they
tried so hard they said Democrats never
they they never storm any buildings they
never Riot or anything they say like
well what about BLM and antifa for eight
freaking months well the Democrats never
questioned the elections um actually
I've got the receipts right here they
constantly question elections with far
less Reason by the way than the
Republicans had in 2020. well the well
the hey Ted keep your voice down
yeah right because he just completely
destroyed your ridiculous narrative with
facts and logic what what he's saying is
there's just two sets of rules here and
so Senator Cruz goes on TV he says
absolutely not uh we're we're uh we're
gonna push back now we're going to not
accept your ridiculous narratives and
and have to clutch our pearls and say
well you know you're right about the
January sixth well you're right about
Donald Trump and the Terry says no you
guys do way worse stuff than we do way
way worse stuff you uh frankly are lying
about the events that the Donald Donald
Trump's denying the election or January
6th or whatever you're lying about it
anyway we're just not going to take it
anymore we're not going to play that
game I think at this point if the
election were fair and square it would
be an absolute Landslide they have to
cheat
they have to cheat it's the only way
that they're going to win right now you
got to go to establishtitles.com Knowles
because I tell you there was a period
when I felt like I wasn't getting no
respect no respect I tell you and then
that all changed thanks to established
titles now I Am Lord Michael Knowles and
you can be a lord or a lady as well you
can get the respect that you deserve all
you need is a one square foot plot of
land in Scotland established titles is a
Project based on an historic Scottish
custom where landowners are referred to
as Lance or Lords and Ladies in English
in your title pack you will be bestowed
with at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate in
edelston Scotland plus an official
certificate with a Crest your
certificate features a unique plot
Number with which you can see the exact
location of your land title packs from
established titles are a fun and unique
gift for any occasion there are even
couple packs because you don't want to
be a Lord and then your poor wife
doesn't get to be a lady with your
certificate you could officially add the
prefix Lord or lady to your credit cards
plane tickets even your dating profiles
a plus established titles commits to
preserving The Woodlands not only in
Scotland but around the planet
they've got Partnerships with global
Charities like one tree planted and
trees for the future to help with our
afforestation efforts and for every
order they receive a tree is planted
established titles told me get this
the first 200 people purchasing a title
pack using my exclusive link will
receive a plot within a few walking
minutes of mine that's right so
depending on how many of you want to
become a lord or a lady we can build our
own kingdom and that will be a wonderful
and it will be run with an iron fist
established titles is actually running a
massive sale right now if you use code
Knolls you'll get on top of that an
additional 10 off go to
establishtitles.com get your gifts right
now and help support the channel
and you're already seeing this happen so
right now I mentioned yesterday on the
show John Federman who's that that
Democrat Senate candidate in
Pennsylvania fetterman finally agreed to
a debate with the Republican candidate
Dr Oz now of course fetterman pushed the
debate as long as he possibly could as
late into the game as possible because
voting's already been going on in
Pennsylvania since September so he's
hoping okay well I'm obviously going to
look terrible at the debate but if I can
encourage enough people to vote before
the debate even happens then it's not
going to matter quite as much and now
John fetterman's campaign is insisting
that he'd be allowed to use an earpiece
during the debate and so why will he use
the earpiece they're saying it's because
he had a stroke
and his health is obviously terrible and
he's certainly not fit to be a U.S
senator he's not morally fit or
intellectually fit but now he's not even
fit as a matter of his own health and so
he needs the earpiece to help with his
quote lingering auditory processing
issues
so they say we are prepared for Dr Oz's
allies and right-wing media to circulate
malicious viral videos after the debate
to try to paint John in a negative light
because of awkward pauses missing some
words and mushing other words together
John has had a remarkable recovery but
the ongoing auditory processing
challenges are real the campaign
insisted on closed captioning technology
because it's necessary so notice what
they're saying malicious awful terrible
viral videos of
John fetterman in his own words
malicious awful terrible dishonest fake
News videos just of this man speaking
isn't it it's so malicious to present
the Democrats
saying what they will say and doing what
they will do but furthermore
do you remember
in years past
when there were these kind of crazy
conspiracy theories that certain weaker
candidates would have an earbud in
during the debate
to get
information you get direction during the
debate and and you say I don't know in
that debate Joe Biden that guy is so
slow but I bet he had an earbud in and
so that's a crazy wild conspiracy theory
now they're just doing it openly now
they're just doing it brazenly they are
actually wearing earbuds and they're
saying yeah we're gonna wear earbuds
during the debate why oh because our
candidate doesn't understand anything
so we need to feed him information
during the debate
yeah yeah
yeah what do you and what are you going
to do about it nothing nothing they're
not even hiding it it's the powers that
be are getting so much more Brazen about
this there was a great this was probably
the greatest tweet of the entire month
it just popped up it's from Max boot you
know he's that fake Republican who
writes for the Washington Post he said
if current trends hold up Republicans
are likely to take over at least the
house and quite possibly the Senate too
along with many State offices this is
how democracies die both at home and
abroad
if current trends hold up the people are
going to elect Republicans
this is how democracies die both at home
and abroad
not sure what that word democracy means
and it well what it shows you is that
the Democrats and the entire liberal
establishment which includes the fake
Republicans as well like you know on The
View they have two fake Republicans Anna
Navarro and that chick from the Trump
Administration but they're they're
effectively Democrats that all they ever
do is support Democrats and Max boot the
same thing he just supports Democrats
and and what they're telling you is that
their their understanding of democracy
has nothing to do with the actual
meaning of the word democracy their
understanding of the word democracy is
the liberal status quo and so when the
people challenge the liberal status quo
when the people speak out against the
lies that were being told when the focus
group from Pennsylvania goes on MSNBC
and says you're actually lying about
this and lying about that and you're
misrepresenting this and we actually
have the facts
then we're told well that's a threat to
demand when the people want their voices
heard
that is of course a threat to democracy
foreign
[Music]